-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here. You made it.
You're watching.
Thank you for tuning in.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, today in Washington,
it was Day 2
of confirmation hearings
for Supreme Court nominee
Ketanji Brown Jackson.
-Whoo!
-Yep, these hearings are never
really fun, but then again,
there's always a paper crinkle
to really liven things up.
Watch this.
Uh, unfortunately,
[ Page turns ]
there's a 77% record --
I'm sorry.
Let me make sure
[ Laughter ]
that this is accurate.
[ Pages turning ]
[ Laughter continues ]
[ Rubbing microphone ]
United States v Platz.
Trump-appointed
Judge Sarah Pitlyk --
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness. Yeah, yeah.
Even old people unwrapping hard
candy at the movies were like,
"Let's go, buddy, come on!"
[ Laughter ]
Chomping on gum.
I love it.
Yeah, Judge Jackson spent
all day answering questions.
Meanwhile, can we see
the Republican senators
who are asking them?
Gosh, it looks like
the Employee of the Month wall
at Cracker Barrel.
[ Laughter ]
But they're really trying
to get people
to watch
the confirmation hearings.
Check out how they started
the broadcast
on CSPAN.
Look at this.
-Here we go!
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clears throat ]
[ Pages turning ]
-Uh, let's see.
-Ump attack.
-Um...
-This is going to be
a wild ride.
-I'm sorry.
-Anything can happen in March!
-Absolute madness!
-Lunch break.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Little cheese break.
That's right,
today Judge Jackson spent hours
answering questions.
Most Senators didn't get
to be there,
but here at "The Tonight Show,"
we got ahold
of the questions
they would've asked.
-Really?
-Yeah, check these out.
First, we have...
They would've asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a question they had.
-Question.
-Up next we have...
He would've asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Finally, we have...
He would've asked..
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a hard no on that one.
What?
Some more news --
President Biden just warned
that Russia could be
exploring options
for cyberattacks
against the U.S.
Isn't that always true?
[ Laughter ]
It's kind of like saying
Michael Bublé is exploring
another Christmas album.
It's like, yeah,
pretty sure it's going
to happen.
[ Laughter ]
Biden said that they could hit
power grids and water supplies.
And people were like, "Cool,
just let us know
when TikTok's in danger, okay?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
to protect yourself online,
experts are saying
that you should make
your passwords longer
than eight characters.
[ Audience murmuring ]
Americans were like, "So,
12345678!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some business news --
Zoom has introduced
a new avatar feature
that lets users
show up to meetings
as an animal,
[ Laughter ]
like a dog, a rabbit, or a fox.
Yeah. There's nothing
like getting laid off
by a fox in the Bahamas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, this is cool --
a company claims it invented
an invisibility shield
that can hide an entire person.
Look at this.
[ Ethereal tune plays ]
-Mm.
♪♪
Mm.
[ Laughter ]
Well, congrats, gang, you just
invented the shower door.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Amazing, really. Wow.
And, finally, a 101-year-old man
who dropped out of high school
in the 1930s
just got his diploma,
more than 80 years later.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Asked what he's going to do now,
the guy said,
"Spring break!"